I don't know how I never managed to
record an intro before I actually make
the video. So, I always have to come
back and post and go ahead and do this,
but we're going to start off with
episode number seven right now. So, we
ended the last video with 64 mil and you
guys will see where we go from that. I
will uh I will warn you. A lot of gains
made in this video. So, look forward to
that and uh I'll see you guys here in a
second. All right. So, as promised, I
said I'd see you guys in a second and I
was not lying. So, go ahead and start
off this video with a slayer task of a
lot of bloodfelds. Then we go over onto
the merch. As you guys can see, I was
working on bucket homes at the time and
uh team cape zeros. So, I made a decent
amount of money off of those. Probably I
think two to 300k if I can remember
correctly off of those. Ended up getting
a superior on task, which is always
nice. I loved getting them in the
catacombs because you get a dark totem
piece every time, which is great.
Eventually I'll make a video with the
compilation of all my loots from him and
doing like all the hard clues. But until
then, just chilling. So went ahead, got
a range level, got up to 74, and then uh
we go ahead and get another task. As you
guys can see, we go ahead and get
trolls, which isn't the best, but it is
what it is. So going to go ahead and go
to the GE right now. All right, so
overnight I ended up doing a pretty big
merch, and that was gilded skimar. So go
ahead and look over here. I bought two
for 19.8 mil, and I went ahead and sold
them for 21.4, which means I made 1.6
mil on these. Really good merch. I could
have made more, but I just wanted to
make sure that I got, you know, at least
a decent amount of profit back on these
and they didn't drop on me overnight.
All right, so after the gilded skin
merch, you know, went ahead and did my
trolls test. Did it with a cannon. Love
using the cannon on the trolls test. But
then we go ahead and get some fire
giants from there. You know the deal.
Mal addiction wards nonstop. So went
ahead made myself a couple. Was making
450k off of each one and uh went ahead
and did a fire giants test. So, this
will obviously be a range level as you
guys can tell. So, go ahead. I think I
get 75 range here, which is always nice.
You guys can still see I have the 450k
in the chat letting me know how much I
made off the malad addiction words.
That's hilarious. But we finish off with
the fire giant task to get more greater
demons. Literally just non-stop task in
the slayer dungeon or catacombs is what
I meant to say. Uh, go ahead and get
more trolls. Trolls are terrible. I hate
them so much. So, obviously I'm going to
use a cannon on them. Uh, just a lot of
slayer to be totally honest with you.
Um, I don't know if commentating over
all these clips is necessarily
necessary. That that really sounds
redundant, but it is what it is. So,
from there, go ahead and get another
superior. Unluckily enough, we still
haven't gotten a unique, but as I said
before, dark totem pieces always
welcome. I figured I'd probably end up
getting it this task. I actually
finished off my totem really early in
this task, so I was happy about that.
And then from there, I go ahead and show
off my Odium Ward collection.
So, after that task, went ahead and got
more trolls. Realistically, it's
non-stop trolls at this point. I can't
wait to get my slayer up and just start
unlocking more and more monsters. So,
from there, as you guys can see, malad
addiction wards were able to sell off
and went ahead and bought on some odiums
for myself. I realized I still had to
buy an Odium Shard 2. And at this point,
Odium Shard 2 prices were really weird.
Like, they shot up from 1 mil probably
to damn near two. And it was just really
hard working with them. Um, as you guys
can see here, I'm going to go ahead and
try to buy it for 1.2, but I'm pretty
sure this takes me a while to buy. So,
from there, go ahead and do my trolls
task. You guys can see I got a slayer
level up to 74. And then from there, we
go ahead and get our next task.
Accidentally recorded the wrong time,
but we got blue dragon, so that wasn't
too bad at all. Went ahead and did the
baby blues because that's the best way
to go about it. And uh, came back for
aberant specs. Aberant specs are
actually nice. So, as you guys can see
there for a second, got a farming level,
but now back on over to the slayer
master per usual and black demon. So,
back into live comp. All right, there we
go. 75 cooking. So, that's a pretty big
milestone actually. I'm just doing jugs
of wine just because it's pretty
relaxing and stuff, but uh trying to
merge something right now. So, I went
and did a little bit of anatis and then
afterwards I sold off my odium ward and
I sold it off for 5.4,
but apparently according to GE Tracker,
it can sell for 5.8. So, we could have a
big margin here if I'm able to buy them,
but I'm not, you know, too I'm not
expecting too much from it, I guess. All
right. So, I know that often I just
drilled the table with my hand, but I
know that you guys don't see me merch
that often. I'm kind of sad by that and
I want to go ahead and show you guys
more merches. So, this is stuff I'm
going to be doing in the future, but
look at this. So, we made 350K
[Music]
pretty much off of each Odium Wars. As
you guys can see, we started with 27.2 2
mil and turn it into basically 29, which
is a 1.8 mil profit. That's insane. And
uh yeah, just going to throw my money
somewhere else, you know. And there we
go. Went ahead and got 30 farming. So, I
know like these are really low levels
and you're like, they're kind of
useless, but I mean, honestly, I'm just
showing this one cuz this unlocks willow
trees, which is kind of nice. And
started doing fruit trees because I just
got 27 farming. Honestly, 1.2k isn't
that bad at all. All right, so this
notes the beginning of the real farming
grind. So, up to 31, but then I go ahead
and do my diagnost task as you guys saw.
Got a strength level and a combat level.
Always welcome. Love getting those
strength levels up. From there, go ahead
and get a cow fights task. Finish that
off. Got more hell hounds. Finished
that. Got fire giants. Just non-stop,
man. And on the fire giants task, you
guys can see coming up now. Went ahead
and got 77 range. Always happy to get a
range level, but uh yeah. So, go ahead,
go back to the GE and finally made all
of my Odium WS. As you guys can see, I
bought them all combined for 29.1 mil
and I believe I was selling them on for
around 30.1. Actually, I sold them for
about a 3 to 4 mil profit, which is
absolutely insane. I do remember that
there was a huge margin on them for a
little while. And as you guys know, I am
definitely down to abuse the margins
that you can find on maladiction shards
and odium shards. So, after I got this
gargoyle test, I went ahead and got
gargoy smasher. Only appropriate. I hate
using the uh the hammer. It is just so
useless. So, so from there, finish up my
task. You guys can see decent amount of
loot. I'll probably take a ring of
wealth on the next task just cuz it's so
tedious picking up the coin drops and I
know I'm missing a ton by not actually
having it on. But as you guys can see,
go ahead and price check it. Uh around
about 360k,
so nothing too bad. Um from there, we go
ahead finish up our greater demons task
for more black demons. Honestly, one of
my favorite tasks in the game. So now
let's get back into livecom. All right,
so there we go. Just hit 78 range.
Almost done with this black demons task.
Afterwards, I might get my prayer up,
honestly, cuz I need to get 70 prayer
just so I can do some pking stuff at
least. I'm 97 combat. I feel kind of
like a noob if I don't have piety. I
don't know if I should, but I mean, it's
it's it's something I need. Time to get
another task, and we end up getting cow
fights. So, one thing that I just did
was I decided to switch up how I
introduce my next clip. So, I'm going to
try to get away from the All right, here
we go. Or, all right, there we go. I
know. I know I say it way too much, but
it's just a habit of mine and I'm trying
to break it, so I was about to say. So,
there we go. God damn it. We're done.
We're done with this clip. I'm ending it
right now. All right, we're about to
make it big time, boys. Let's go ahead
and do this. I mean, you guys you guys
aren't going to have any clue what the
hell's going on. You guys You guys are
like, "What? What's he doing? Why is he
typing a dragon into the chat? What's he
going to do?" And I'm just like, "Boom.
Give me the [__] bones, boy. I want
them there. Boom. Give me them all.
We're going to go do a little bit of
prayer. We're going to get this prayer
level up, boys. All right. After a
little bit of calculations, I realized
that wasn't going to be enough. There we
go. And you know damn well where this is
going. So, went ahead and got some
prayer levels. However, you'd think I'd
get 70 right here in this little
stretch, right? A little surprise here
in a second, but prayer is definitely
something I need to train. Really happy
to do it. I mean, honestly, not having
piety at my level is pretty
embarrassing. And this half makes up for
not having Barrel's gloves. All right,
so here we are. Um, I said a while back
I was doing a giveaway on Twitter for
the Super Bowl kind of thing. So, this
is going to be the winner. I'm going to
ask him what he wants to do since it
took me a while to get back on this. I
feel kind of bad. So, I'll give him his
choice. So, the giveaway was 2.5 mil or
if the Falcons won, it was supposed to
be a one and four chance at 10 mil. I'll
let him choose what he wants and we'll
give him what he needs. All right. So,
he wants seven chances. We'll see how
this goes. So, he has to pick seven
numbers between one and 28. All right.
So, we're going to put it right there.
Number seven. That's what we'll do. So
he has to pick seven numbers in between
1 and 28. And uh if he hits a 10 mil, he
hits it. All right. So he said 14. All
right. So there are two of his options.
Oh, I was thinking about putting in an
eight. Oh god, he's getting close. Guess
lower, man. Guess lower. Come on. Don't
guess higher. There we go. There we go.
How many times have I said no? One, two,
three, four, five.
I think he has two more guesses. 10 mil
is actually a decent amount to me. Oh
god. All right. He has one last guess.
All right. So, he didn't end up guessing
it. I'm sorry, man. I'll give him I'll
give him 500k, though, just cuz I don't
want to I don't want to run off with all
of it. I'll give some away, though.
Thanks for trying though, man. And uh
yeah, look forward to future giveaways
like this every now and then. Sometimes
I like to have fun with it. Like right
here. Well, too bad about that guy, but
I got to continue on with my prayer
grind. So, after he uh messaged me and
whatnot, I went ahead and went and
talked to him and did that whole thing.
But then afterwards, I'm like, you know
what? I gotta get back on this grind. So
went ahead and uh in kind of climatic
fashion, I went ahead and just showed
like the final five bones just to have
you guys get a little taste of the grind
that I was on. It's not too bad though.
55 to like 70s, piece of cake. So from
there, went ahead and got a black team's
task. I thought I was going to be cool
and like flick py, but then I realized
I'm like, I don't want to do that. So
went ahead did my dragons task and then
got hell hounds, but as you guys can
see, I do love farming so much.
Honestly, it's so nice and I've been
progressing it now. I do these a week
late for just in case I need to upload
something in between. But as you guys
can see, just on a constant farming
grind up to 36 and 37 in this clip. And
then we get 87 strength there. All
right. So, just went ahead uh on this
test. Got a couple big levels as you
guys saw earlier. Got the strength
level. Also got a slayer level and an HP
level. So, we probably won't get another
combat level for a while. Oh, here we
go. Time to get another task. Calhound's
just done. Come on, man. I want like a I
want a wyvern task so bad. But I mean
there are actual good tests that we can
get now. Like we can get like curus
which I cancelled in the last video. So
skeleton wyverns gargo. I should do
desert treasure cuz dest levels are
actually really good.
Oh my god, I almost just spilled my
drink. All right, so here we go. Going
to end off the video. So uh All right,
so here we are. This is the end of the
video. Going to go ahead and calculate
what our bank is worth. So give me one
second.
And there it is. So 52 mil. Well, that
doesn't seem like a lot. Well, we have
something else in our uh in our uh grand
exchange. So, as you guys can see, I
have 16.7 mil here, which in total means
we have about 68 to 69 mil in total on
this account. Obviously, I could take a
black mask out of my slayer helm. I
could take some of the darts and and uh
scales out of my blowpipe. So, there's a
little bit of money there that's hiding.
Uh, one of the big reasons we didn't
make as much this episode is because we
had to spend a little bit on prayer.
But, with that done, we should be good
on prayer for a while. So, that's a big
achievement. uh up to 1326 total, which
is insane, and slowly just grinding that
to the point where I'm content with it.
But with that being said, that'll be the
end of the video. I hope you guys
enjoyed. If you guys did, make sure to
leave a like if you guys enjoy all of my
content, or at least, you know, just a
little bit. Feel free to hit that sub
button. Uh comment down below anything
you guys want to see in the future, what
I should do with my account, and any
suggestions you guys have. Twitter's in
the description. And with that being
said, hope you guys have a wonderful
day, and peace. Oh, now time to go start
episode 8 and do one small favor. Kill
me. All right. So, here we go. Going to
All right. So, here we are. This is the
end of the video. So, going All right.
So, here we are. This is the end of the
video. Everything is going
All right. So, here we are. This is the
end.